being able to grip and hold down is
virtually impossible that pursuit is
designed for one person hi i'm mike
elliott a 26-year combat veteran i
served 11 years with the u.s army golden
knight parachute team i have over 16 000
skydives 6 000 tandems 100 static line
jumps and about 20 military free fall
jumps today we're gonna be looking at
parachuting scenes and movies and judge
how real they are
i think you did the correct procedures
with military free fall jumpers with
combat equipment they have their o2 mass
zone goggles it's a lot of moving parts
so there is a possibility that something
should come loose it takes about 15
seconds to fix his o2 pipe and put it
back to his helmet you can hold your
breath up to a minute and still be okay
so he had plenty of time to fix his mask
and still leave the aircraft
his body position is very correct here
he's in what we call a die position and
it is so uber important to have the
correct body position basically you have
to learn how to push air with your body
so the wind is basically hitting him
around his waist and chest area which
allows that wind to be symmetrical
around his body so he can gain stability
after he exits the yak rack
25 000 feet he did a very great job um
as a halo jumper basically halo is high
high altitude low opening meaning you
exit the aircraft above 15 000 feet you
have to have some type of breeding
breathing apparatus in the aircraft as
well as on your body as far as the form
is concerned there's no different form
with halo it's called the the box man
position or the arch position everything
he's doing in this scene is done
correctly your knees are bent your
pelvis is pushed forward your arms are
back
that is a pretty gnarly looking storm i
have never had to jump into uh clouds
and lightning and it's not even approved
by the federal aviation administration
with clouds you cannot see the ground
and you can get struck by lightning and
if you're flying with other jumpers now
you're at a risk of running into another
person and when you slam into another
person at 120 miles per hour it's going
to be some serious injuries
i i do like that the body position of
both actors in this movie are correct
and if you're unconscious you're going
to be on your back because your arms and
legs are the lowest portions of your
body so gravity will put you on your
back i would rate this um a high seven
for sure all those are very unique
maneuvers that could possibly happen
well very uh unrealistic scene there is
no way um anyone could have made it
through that type of debris to bring it
more home i was uh at an altitude about
14 000 feet and we had some icing
conditions when we stepped out of the
airplane and it was the most painful
thing that i think i've ever experienced
it was like being shot in the face with
a bb gun so if he can think about
getting hit by piece of that debris
there's no way um i would have left that
building with a parachute whatsoever
you could catch up with someone in free
fall that position she was in the full
delta position you straighten your legs
and you pull your arms against your body
so there's nothing out there that's
going to create the wind from flowing
around your body so you can get up to
250 to 280 miles an hour easy i'm not
going to say this particular episode was
realistic for every
action there's a reaction in free fall
if you're looking up trying to find
someone that's going to change your
whole body position and it's going to
change their airflow of symmetry around
your body so you're going to slow down
you're going to come out of that dive
i don't know if anyone that has put a
parachute on in midair in order to to
put those leg straps around your legs
put your arms in that harness at 120
miles an hour with debris falling around
you i don't believe that is possible i
would say one
nothing in this clip to me looks real
whatsoever
a total high five on this scene from the
ramp to the exit with the a military
free-fall operation um each group this
excellent aircraft has a team leader and
you're guiding all the guys so
are grouping around him so they can see
what's going on and that's the same
formation they stay in during their exit
and as they get out into free fall
as you see here they jump in at night
time everything gets really really
difficult at night time because either
flying through nods or just with your
naked eye and you can't see obstacles
you can't see the ground coming up and
in the army you have the round static
line jumps from like the 80 second
everyone division and you have the army
parachute team which are demonstrations
and competitive type guys on the special
operations side u.s navy
seals or delta force or special forces
these guys are trained to put that
parachute where they need to put it to
do what they need to do best so if these
guys are illustrating from a spec op
side
yes that is something that can can
definitely be done
in this particular scene they're doing a
halo special operation soldiers their
thing is to be as stealthly and as quiet
and as dark as they can and the premise
of a halo jump is soldiers could step
out up to 40 or 50 miles away at 25 000
feet open their parachute by 20 000 feet
and they can drift in
quietly steadily undetected from miles
away for this i don't know why they
would have smoke especially you can't
see smoke at night time it's mandatory
to have blinking lights on your body and
when you're flying at nighttime so other
aircraft could see you special operation
guys they're not going to have any
lights and flares because they're coming
in um as definitely as quiet as possible
so they can do the mission uh once they
get on the ground
the landing as you see it's an extremely
tight area the tight parachutes that are
a military especially up guys it's
called mc4s mc5s
very big very docile parachutes they
definitely can land on buildings and in
tight areas i don't think they would
land in something that tight not a bad
looking clip at all i would give them a
six
but i don't know how to parachute that's
okay we're gonna tandem jump
trust me
first of all when was that moment that
you put a tandem parachute and a tandem
harness inside of the airplane yeah i
was the the team leader for the tandem
team on the us army parachute team and i
was selected to jump with former
president bush in order to do a tandem
jump it takes a good 15 to 20 minutes to
don that harness as well as his
parachute system and you have to watch a
waiver video and go through the
procedures because the license
experience tenant structure could take a
person with no experience and he can go
through the thrills of free falling they
just didn't have enough time to prepare
for a tandem operation while in flight
ready
[Music]
that is a correct exit to use a seated
position to leave from the aircraft
normally if you're doing a seated
position you have someone that's really
nervous of the jump or a little heavier
so a city position is the best way to
get them out the door into the relative
wind
[Music]
if you notice there's a cord coming out
of the back of dwayne johnson's
parachute that is called a drogue
because of the speed of two people
together normal speed if one person in
free fall is about 120 miles an hour
well for a tandem that speed increases
to about 180 miles an hour so you have
to set that drill got which is basically
a smaller
round parachute to slow you back down to
120 miles an hour
[Music]
you see him here tapping her and that
tap is for her to bring her arms back
into her body because he's getting ready
to open up the parachute you don't want
the passenger to grab handles during
that opening process because you have
two folks on under one canopy the canopy
is a lot bigger so things have to open a
lot higher a normal tandem opening
procedure starts at 5500 feet if you're
doing a solo jump you can take it down
as low as 2500 feet and if you notice in
the clip the drill kind of collapses and
the parachute comes out very proper
opening technique i'm gonna rate this
about
a four um simply because the training
technique inside of the aircraft
wow i mean every time i i see a
static line operation
depth it gives me chill bumps to think
about um soldiers in world war ii the
forefathers of parachuting with static
line jumping it's the most expedient way
to put soldiers on the battlefield if
you look at some of the actual footage
that happened on d-day in market gardens
that's basically what you see numerous
numerous parachutes in the air at any
given time
[Music]
so this is absolutely 100 correct i was
actually an airborne instructor for
three years where i train parachutes how
to become paratroopers and uh the best
way to get out the aircraft is basically
you pushing the guy in front of you out
the door so you can get out to do as
quick as possible and as you exit you
get into a good tight body position
which is your hands over your harness
feet knees together and that static line
actually pulls your parachute out and
your parachute opens automatically i'm
going to rate this as a 10. i'm just
amazing any and every time i see what
the guy's done for us back in world war
ii
there are so many different facets of
maneuvering your body through the air
it's called free-flying you can fly on
on your feet you can fly on your head
you can fly in a ball and it's all about
learning how to maneuver air with your
body and whatever position you're in so
yes this is very very accurate what he's
doing
we can stop here for a second they were
portraying that you can talk in the air
at 120 miles an hour falling 176 feet
per second you cannot hear anything but
the air rushing past your ears
[Music]
well what a long free fall so i don't
know what
altitude they exited the aircraft from
but obviously it was not above 15 000
feet because they don't have o2 mass on
at 12 000 feet you're looking at about
45 seconds of free fall time so here we
are still falling
so um wow that must got it really really
high
[Music]
a lot of this happens on the golden
knights the golden knights have a
a free-fall formation team a eight-way
team that go out and do these
geometrical formations this formation
we're looking at is called a star
formation and what they're doing is very
correct as you see he's kind of coming
in nice and slow you have to slow your
body down to approach it to make sure
you don't take that formation out when
you see the guys that are grabbing each
other's wrists that is called taking a
dock on the person to your left to your
right in order to consider it being a
built formation you have to hold on to
another person either by their jumpsuit
about their wrists by their arms and
then for them to have inexperienced
jumper and make it to a formation with
no problems that's never going to happen
the irish person that can build a
formation this size probably has about a
hundred jumps when you're watching a
movie that it shows a guy just putting
on the parachute and jumping out of an
airplane that is nowhere near close to
absolutely happening that's a lot of
time a lot of training that goes behind
doing a parachute operation so i'm going
to say a five for this one
[Music]
very very realistic of what kind of
canopy is felony celine a seven-seal
demonstration parachute made for
pinpoint landing his exit procedure his
hand when he deploys the parachutes all
correct by bringing my hand over my head
that keeps the air symmetrical around
our body so i still gain the stability
during the opening process of my
parachute
that's how you enter a party
i love it i've jumped into the the
pentagon did a lot of pretty unique
places you have to submit a air request
through the federal revolution
administration they're going to be the
ones that approve you to jump in the
land of these different areas
[Music]
so they're a little little close in this
actual landing by the faa and united
states parish association you can land
no closer than 15 feet from people and
you can fly no lower than 15 feet above
their heads when you see them come
across the folks heads and land right in
front of them you would have a little
more distance to that and you would have
to have a marked off drop zone meaning
with a safety officer on the ground
controlling the crowd now if you notice
he looks like he's just painting the
controls with his index finger and his
thumb um i wouldn't advise that because
there's so much pressure on those
toggles toggles are very very important
it's like the the brakes on the car to
keep those toggles secure so you make a
fits around your control or if you like
um golden knights we fly with our hands
above the toggles wrapped into a fist
for safe soft stand up landing as you
see him coming in here as soon as he
pulled down to stop his parachute he
would lose his toggles
what a wonderful day to become a knight
yes you can get out of the equipment
pretty quick basically it's only three
points of connection you have the chest
strap and your two leg straps so if you
have quick releases as soon as your feet
hit the ground you pop your two leg
connectors you pop your chest strap you
let the pressure fall off your shoulders
just a few minute things on his landing
but everything else as long as he had
the correct approvals
looks real good so we're gonna give him
an eight
being able to grip and hold down is
virtually impossible that purse shirt is
designed for one person and you're not
hooked up properly as if you're doing a
tandem but if i knew there was a
possibility that person could save both
our lives then i would make that that
attempt to do that
[Music]
i was trying to to look and see what
their all terminal reading was and i
couldn't really see i see it's flashing
low altitude but we have no idea of how
low they are before they open up their
main parachute 2500 feet is when you
open up your main parachute takes time
for those things to fully and opens with
today's parachute systems we have what
we call an automatic opening device it's
going to open up the reserve parachute
for you and that is designed to open at
a low altitude so your main parachute
which they're using in this scene that
could open up at that lower altitude
is not very realistic
[Music]
to have someone attached to you and land
on a target that's not doing a tandem
absolutely impossible this is called
parachute accuracy two people under one
parachute somebody's gonna break some
ankles for sure in that case they should
have did what we call a a parachute
landing fall where you hit the balls of
your feet calves thighs and your
buttocks which is the softest part of
your body so trying to land and roll to
those soft sides of your body is kind of
what they did in this scene um but
there's just no way that you can even
see around that person enough to fly
that parachute to a target area i'm
gonna rate these guys at a five
i i love the fact that they did
highlight on his parachute not being
hooked up properly what we have here is
three ring release system on his chest
strap you see the two um conduits
hanging out of his main lift web which
kind of
started the whole malfunction that he
was sabotaged
[Music]
he wastes a lot of time trying to fight
this uh malfunction if at any given time
um look up and this thing is not flying
properly you have to start your cutaway
procedures meaning you have two handles
you have a cutaway handle to get rid of
the bad parachute and then you have your
secondary handle which is going to
deploy your auxiliary your reserve
parachute so he's sitting here he's
playing with this this canopy and he's
losing altitude and time quickly
anything lower than 800 or nine hundred
feet you stand a chance of it not
opening so now by time he does cut it
away he's at a lower altitude to get his
reserve out
and as you can see then now his reserve
handle was not working when you have a
cutaway and you have to fire your
reserve there's really not a lot of
tension so you can't you have the
strength to pull that reserve handle out
before i pick up my parachute i do
overall inspection of it each and every
time that's just safety procedures in
the sport so very unlikely that that
you're going to have a sabotage
parachute nowadays
yeah the guy would have never made it to
his rescue for about every four seconds
in free phone you lose about a thousand
feet so
as we watch him go through his his
malfunction he's probably in free fall
for three or four seconds trying to get
that reserve to open up and a guy's
gonna cut away from his main open
parachute to come down and try to save
him there's not enough altitude in the
world for him to do that in this given
situation by that time he would have
impacted the ground for sure i'm gonna
rate this at a seven and we know at the
bottom and it got a little dramatic my
favorite parachuting scene is in the
longest day if you ever go to france you
can see that particular church this
still has a parachute hung up i truly
love all of the world war ii movies that
show what our soldiers were up against
during that time frames thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video why
not click on the video above